donald trump has still not taken
questions from reporters it's been about
a month now it's been since before the
election
that we have not actually seen donald
trump take
questions from reporters yesterday
suddenly haphazardly a presidential
press conference
was called it was in the briefing room
at the white house
and it lasted this is not a mistake okay
64 seconds not minutes
64 seconds is all that it was
assembling the press corps for donald
trump
to take no questions and delusionally
brag about medical advancements and the
dow jones industrial average
hitting 30 000 during trading yesterday
take a look at this
now normally i say this thing went on an
hour
it went on an hour and a half i can't
play the whole thing for you
i am playing the entire press conference
for you today okay not a portion of it
let's start
well thank you very much and i just want
to congratulate everybody
the stock market dow jones industrial
average just hit 30 000 which is the
highest in history
we've never broken thirty thousand and
that's just despite
uh everything that's taken place with
the pandemic i'm very
uh thrilled with what's happened on the
vaccine front that's been
absolutely incredible i find it sort of
hilarious
that donald trump comes in and says he
wants to congratulate everybody
congratulate everybody for doing what
exactly i mean just a bizarre
start a comedy of errors like every
little
detail is hilarious and pathetic that
was the first
23 seconds of the 64.
let's now get to more of this we're i'm
showing you everything we're going to
pick it up right where we left off
it's nothing like that has ever happened
medically
and i think people are acknowledging
that and it's having a big effect but
the stock market's just broken thirty
thousand never been broken that number
that's a sacred number thirty thousand
nobody thought they'd ever see it
sorry okay i i have to stop once more
30 000 is a sacred number what
what is he talking about how is that
even a remotely sensible thing to say
it's sacred to get to thirty thousand
what
i don't even know what that's supposed
to mean and then here are the last 25
seconds
uh that's the ninth time since uh
the beginning of 2020 and it's the 48th
time
that we've broken records in during
the trump administration and i just want
to congratulate all the people within
the administration that worked so hard
and most importantly i want to
congratulate the people of our country
because there are no people like you
thank you very much everybody thank you
so that is the full press conference
64 seconds with mike pence
standing behind him with this kind of
doofy smirk
on his face to say congratulations to
the american people
i guess for hitting the sacred number
of 30 000 in the dow jones industrial
average
and to claim that we've seen medical
advancements like we've never seen
before
thanks to his presidency and to still
take no questions
how bizarre is this this i you know
i am uh i am not a person who lacks
empathy donald trump seems seems unable
to
experience the feeling of empathy i i
don't lack empathy
and in watching these very sad
64 seconds i actually came
close to thinking about maybe
feeling slightly bad for trump just
deflated
grasping for anything that he can say or
do
to keep his grip on relevance as the
transition to joe biden's presidency
continues and it seems like trump feels
it slipping away like
grant grains on a sandy beach slipping
through one's fingers
uh it's strange to see donald trump keep
trying to sell himself to the american
people after losing an election
and one other funny note back during the
transition period
into trump's administration donald trump
took credit
for the rise in the stock market in
november
and december and early january remember
barack obama was still president then
but donald trump took credit and said no
no once i got elected stocks started
going up even before i was inaugurated
thanks to me
that's the opposite of what he's doing
here he is now
saying even though the stock market is
going up
after joe biden has been elected
he as the lame duck president still gets
credit for the stock
market going up at this point you know
hypocrisy is dead and double standards
have no meaning with this administration
but just sort of like as a side note
outgoing here
um not even worth arguing with him not
even worth arguing with trumpists about
you know don't let the door hit you on
the way out but yet
another one of these instances of donald
trump holding himself
to a completely different standard than
he held barack obama to
and that applies to joe biden and that
applies to hillary clinton and it
applies to
uh essentially anybody that would be
seen as not
friendly to donald trump in the space of
politics so
he's slowly being deflated i still
doubt that we will ever again see donald
trump do
a full actual press conference before
leaving office
where he takes questions and he's not
even going to be punished for it by his
followers because they will say he's
right not to take questions
the media colluded with biden and
they're all against him and they're
fake why would he give them the ratings
of letting them ask him questions so
that's what they'll say
trump will sort of fade away and he may
i mean listen we we may after christmas
as has been suggested
he may just leave dc and that'll be it
no appearance at the inauguration would
not be at all surprising although
for for optics sake i would be
fascinated to see donald trump at the
inauguration
of president joseph r biden jr we've got
a great show for you today today will be
like a friday show
because it is the last show of the week
we are off tomorrow and friday for the
thanksgiving holiday but we are here
today one more show
and then we'll be on a little bit of a
break for a limited time
our sponsor purevpn is offering you a
huge 86 percent discount on a
subscription
which comes out to only about a dollar
fifty per month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online
and you can trust them because they're
the only vpn in the industry with an
always-on
third-party audit to verify that your
internet activity is not being
logged by hiding your ip address purevpn
keeps you safe from hackers
and prevents you from being spied on by
your internet service provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than
any other vpn in the industry everyone
should be using
a vpn when connecting to the internet
and now is the perfect time to start
because purevpn is giving you an 86
percent discount on a subscription
which comes out to only about a dollar
fifty a month go to davidpakman.com
purevpn the link is underneath this
video